- But last year you got married, right?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Yes.
Did everything go as
planned, or was anything-
- Yeah, I mean, most
of it went as planned.
I tried to, I, you know,
we did the best we could.
We had a wedding planner,
but you know, like life-
- [Kelly] Yep.
- Things happen and you have
to sort of go with the flow.
- Yeah.
- I mean,
there was an issue with
the bus that was supposed
to take everyone from
the hotel to the venue,
which was less than a mile by the way,
so they could have walked,
and it would've been less problematic,
but it hit a curb, then hit another curb.
- [Kelly] What?
- Got lost.
- Is everyone okay?
Got lost, and it was a mile away.
- And then tried to drop everyone off
in the middle of nowhere.
- Was the driver inebriated?
(laughing) like.
- No.
- I was like, "Wait."
I think maybe there was a wrong-
- Miscommunication.
- Yes.
I don't wanna throw anyone
under the bus, so to speak.
- Yeah.
- But it was-
- On TV. (laughing)
- That's right.
But it was, it ended up
being fine, but there...
And no one really wanted
to bring it up to me,
but then of course, my best
friend was like, "Oh my God,
it was a disaster."
- [Kelly] Yeah. (laughing)
- We were all on the side of the road,
and we were like, "We don't
think this is it, and..."
But then you just sort
of go with the flow,
and not take it too seriously.
- [Kelly] I saw the pictures.
It looked magical.
That flower thing behind you.
The wall of beauty.
- [Guest] Beautiful.
- [Kelly] Yeah, and that's so cute.
You're such a handsome couple, anyway.